exploding heads billy joel loves sausage
and child abuse
season two had it all for those of you
who haven't seen my boys videos
welcome have a fresca we have a lot to
cover today going over the biggest
details of season two
and what it could mean for season three
we have the fate of black noir the
meaning behind the saint christopher
necklace
what will happen to stormfront and the
german translation of what her
not so final words are so grab an almond
joy and warm glass of milk because here
we
go oh and make sure to like and
subscribe while you're at it if you
watched my last video you'll know the
penultimate episode
ended with a bang
everyone is still reeling from the
events at the house judiciary hearing
one which was supposed to reveal vots
true plan to create an army of white
supremacist soups or at least that's
what stormfront wanted to create we know
stan
edgar the hetovot was working with
stormfront because of the emails
starlight uncovered back in episode 5.
even though stan is black for him it's
just business
so it's just business tonight when
mr butcher in history has it ever been
about anything different
vaught was the company that hid
stormfront for over 40 years after her
alter ego
liberty disappeared in 1979. at the end
of the episode we learn from homelander
that she is still
alive in an undisclosed facility so
there's a reason they're keeping her
around and i think it's more than her
ability to make a crowd angry
as stan edgar puts it stormfront's good
at making people angry
angry people want compound v compound v
raises our stock price stormfront has to
come back not only was she arguably one
of the most talked about characters
the writers would have simply killed her
off if they were done with her we also
haven't even skimmed the surface of her
backstory how she fell in love with
frederick vaught and if you've seen some
of my previous videos you'd know my
crazy theory that she's actually jewish
and that they met at the dachau
concentration camp where he first tested
compound v
how she'll come back considering she
looks like anakin skywalker isn't
exactly known
but with a show that involves
superheroes anything is possible
she could come back as some sort of
cyborg or as i theorize
may be given a new vote therapy
synthesized from
gecko remember that gecko used to work
for vaught as a human guinea pig because
he had the ability to regrow body parts
we also don't know much about stan edgar
and more specifically his relationship
with stormfront
i don't find it convincing he'd keep a
no nazi in hiding for 40 years just to
use her to rile up crowds at rallies
i think stan edgar is frederick vaught
or perhaps some
manifestation of him it would explain
his close relationship with stormfront
how he has a picture of frederick vaught
in his office
and how he goes on and on to homelander
about how amazing he was
remember that vaught was considered the
world's best geneticist so
anything in the show is within the realm
of possibility in this hilarious psa to
students
of what to do in the event of a soup
attack homelander explains the most
important thing
everyone should remember survival is all
that matters
and that's really what homelander learns
himself at the end of the episode when
confronted with whether or not to kill
butcher
he makes a decision that's best for his
survival letting butcher and ryan go so
that maeve doesn't release the footage
of him
and the downed airliner it adds even
more irony to the scene of him
love sausaging on the edge of a
skyscraper he says the lines
i can do whatever i want over and over
again but the irony is he can't oh and
if you check out vaudamerica.com it
unfortunately leads to an error message
on the sony website the company that
produces the show
gloria mallory and congresswoman newman
speak with the secretary of defense bob
singer in the wake of the head exploding
attack they want him to talk to the
president and put a stop to vott's
alleged coup but his hands are tied
if vaught took a [ __ ] in the middle of
fifth avenue they'd throw a ticker tape
parade
which is a reference to president donald
trump where i could stand in the middle
of fifth avenue and shoot somebody and i
wouldn't lose any voters okay
newman and mallory will need more proof
if they're going to stop vots
distribution of compound v
but what's really interesting about this
scene now that we know newman is the
soup responsible for exploding all those
heads
thanks eric kripke and that brilliant
red herring of making us think it was
cindy
is why newman would want to save vot her
motivations
are completely unknown on the one hand
she publicly denounces vaught
on the other she secretly kills anyone
like vogelbaum in episode 7
who gets in vaught's way what's her plan
we know that at the end of the season
she's appointed the new sar of soup
affairs so she'll have access to tons of
resources to track soups she even
appoints grace mallory to head an
off-the-book group to keep
tabs on the supes basically a boys 2.0
she also kills the head of the church of
the collective which was a thorn in both
vaught and the government's side and may
have also been retaliation for him
taking credit for the release of
stormfront's nazi past
the event which put on hold the release
of compound v
starlight's journey this season has been
about going from non-belief to belief
not belief in a god per se but believing
you can make a difference
she starts the season telling gekko
there's nobody in sky
watching over us not god not a
homelander
not anybody and later tells her mother
the good guys don't win
the bad guys don't get punished what we
do means nothing
it's just all for money it's pretty
pessimistic and echoes what maeve says
in the final episode
it doesn't matter what we do nothing
changes
nothing ever changes or gets better
starlight must believe that they can
make a difference if they're going to
convince mabe
she completes her character arc by
putting on her mother's necklace a
symbol of something she once thought
meant nothing
if billy butcher can do the right thing
then
there's gotta be some kind of higher
power
we find out the fate of black noir who
was taken down by an almond joy he's
survived his allergic reaction
and all we know is that the doctors
don't think there's brain damage
expect him to be back in season 3.
stormfront tells homelander that it
wasn't her who did the attack in
washington and tells him that this event
will allow them to step away from the
paparazzi and movie premieres for a
while
but little does she know that's what he
loves he's a narcissist
he craves the attention more than her
crusade for white
power he learns that stormfront wants to
put compound v into the hands of the
right people meaning
white people and that frederick had a
quote solution to keeping it out of the
hands of anyone else
and easy to misreference to hitler's
final solution
stan edgar meets with the head of the
church of the collective to negotiate
bringing the deep and a train back into
the
seven but he'll only allow the deep in
which is what prompts a-train to steal
stormfront's records from the church's
files
stormfront used to be a member of the
church when adana's grandfather started
it decades ago
hence why they have a file on her later
on in the episode a train will get back
into the seven while the deep is cut off
the main thing keeping a train from the
seven was stormfront's dislike of him
probably because she's a raging racist
and hates black people and with her out
of the picture he's free to get back
in the deep on the other hand is
rejected leaving his character for next
season a total wild card with adana out
of the picture and the deep shafted by
the organization he thought could get
him back into the seven
we'll likely see him doing his own thing
again next season
becca escapes the compound and rushes
for butcher's help after homelander left
with her son
ryan last episode this is the main plot
of the end here and highlights butcher's
transformative character arc going from
someone who wanted nothing to do with
ryan
he's a [ __ ] suit freak too willing to
sacrifice his life for him his initial
plan is to give ryan to stan
edgar to be used as leverage over
homelander allowing butcher to be with
becca
the thing he wants more than anything in
the world but when becca makes butcher
promise to bring ryan safely back to her
he renegs on the deal with vot
his moral compass outweighed his desire
to selfishly keep becca to himself
in other words he wasn't a [ __ ] remember
what i told you
don't be a [ __ ] also shout out to the
show to having ashley's hair falling out
become a thread throughout the season
i think this is mainly caused by stress
more than anything i wouldn't look too
far into it homelander and stormfront
take ryan to planet vaude a rip-off of
planet hollywood they're shortly
bombarded by fans making ryan
uncomfortable
remember he's never been around large
groups of people before having spent his
entire life on that vaught compound
homelander will take ryan to his
secluded cottage the same one where he
had sexy times with madeleine
stillwell's doppelganger there's an
interesting conversation between huey
and starlight where he talks about his
mother still being alive she just got up
one day and
left it's an interesting combo to have
especially for the final episode leading
me to believe they may be setting up his
mother for
season 3. also that's the reason why
there's so many damned billy joel songs
throughout the season he used to have
dance parties listening to billy with
his mom homelander rarely shows
empathy but does so with his son telling
him when he was his age he was scared of
his powers too he'll teach him how to
work on them
even his laser eyes on an action figure
of the deep these laser eyes are what
will eventually slice stormfront apart
and kill his own mother now the
interesting thing here is that
stormfronts seem to be impervious to
homelanders laser eyes does this mean
brian's are more powerful
but before we get there we need to talk
about girls get it done
no not the female empowerment campaign
but this
a particular note here is kimiko
overcoming her fear of confronting
stormfront
at the end of episode 3 she froze while
stormfront killed her brother kenji
something she feels guilty about a lot
of people predicted kimiko would be the
one to kill stormfront but since she's
technically still alive maybe she
still has a chance oh and can we talk
about how homelander was like what the
[ __ ]
when stormfront brought up white
genocide stormfront's nazi past is
revealed to the public halting the
production and sale of compound v to the
public
and check out this hilarious attention
to detail on the news report linking
jeffrey epstein's death to stormfront
and bonus points if you saw a homelander
enjoying a nice glass of milk while
chilling with his son
frenchie creates a sonic device to
distract homelander giving butcher and
becca enough time to save ryan
remember that frenchie is great at
making improvised devices to take down
soups
well the one in episode 6 really didn't
work so we won't mention that anyway
that's why he was brought onto the boys
by grace mallory years ago
he's got a much better handle on
kimiko's sign language after learning
his first word of it last episode
and he ends the season leaving with
kimiko a free man
stormfront stops becca butcher and ryan
from leaving even getting stabbed in the
eye in the process
which will be kind of cool if she has an
eye patch next season but as stormfront
kills becca ryan
lasers her to pieces killing becca in
the process
as she dies she tells butcher to let
ryan know it's not his fault that he's a
good boy
homelander arrives and finds his love
burnt and in pieces whispering something
in german which translates to
it was so beautiful how the three of us
sat there in the shade of an apple tree
do you remember the day frederick
chloe's arms out of the car window
we found the perfect spot by the river
in the shade of an apple tree it was the
first time chloe ate fresh apples
she's remembering a day with her
frederick and their daughter chloe who
we saw an older version of in her photos
homelander is about to kill butcher and
take ryan but is stopped by maeve who
threatens to expose the plane incident
to the world he then threatens to
destroy the entire world but
maeve calls his bluff if he kills
everyone no one will be around to love
him and that's what separates butcher
from homelander homelander isn't willing
to give up the thing he loves most for
ryan his fame
and adoration by the people whereas
butcher gives up
everything in fact when maeve tells
homelander he'll lose all that love
we hear this in homelanders mind
love was something homelander never had
as a child and that's why he craves it
and can't live without it he's willing
to give up his son
not to lose it once again vat has
spinned the stormfront nazi story saying
that maeve and starlight brought her
down
allowing starlight to rejoin the seven
how she'll survive in this environment
with vaught and homelander knowing her
true past helping the boys
is unknown but it looks like vot has to
keep her in the seven to save
face huey tells starlight he needs to
let go
not of her but of being clingy
especially to people like butcher
he clung onto them because he never
wanted them to leave like his mother did
but for him to move on he'll need to go
out on his own
which is why he ends up joining
congresswoman newman's campaign
setting him up perfectly for season 3.
butcher has a final chat with ryan who
will end up being taken into cia custody
to be hidden from homelander
a particular note is the necklace of
saint christopher which was given to him
by becca
he'll give it to ryan as a reminder of
his mother but the necklace has a hidden
meaning
according to legend saint christopher
tells the story of a man who carried a
child who was unknown to him
across a river before the child reveals
himself as
christ i guess it's fitting then that
this scene takes place in front of a
river
butcher in this story is saint
christopher helping the unknown boy he
didn't even know about till the end of
season 1.
the question then remains will ryan
become this christ-like savior
will he be the one to eventually take
down homelander
as ryan goes off grace informs butcher
that all the charges against the boys
have been dropped but that she wants him
to stay on board as she continues the
group
under congresswoman newman's command
butcher just walks away but he'll likely
be back along with mother's milk who is
reunited with his daughter
the boys know how important their job is
and now that the specter of the
government
taking them down is no longer there
they'll probably be gung-ho to take on
homelander and bot knowing all the crazy
[ __ ] they're up to
all in all the ending of season 2 was
fantastic offering ironic twists and
setting us up for another
batshit season thanks for watching
everyone please make sure to like and
subscribe and leave a comment
about what you thought of the season
below for more bad takes you can follow
me on twitter and instagram at
thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy's home